what's been taking up your time like
game wise what have you been diving into
there's so much
out right now we're kind of spoiled i
feel like definitely
uh i i switch it up um i like the action
action shooting games i play all of them
and then i'll play some
some sports games here and there uh just
like 1v1 against some friends
um and i still have a nintendo 64 that
will hop in on the
place of mario so it's super mario so i
got a variety of them
a little dash of old school did you buy
the 64 recently or is that like your 64.
i've had it it's got like the
see-through it's see-through you can see
like the
whatever's inside the little green i
have a green box or whatever so you see
what's inside it and you're always
blowing on the disc to make it work it's
pretty cool i got the og1
nice what an era i know i missed i
missed those days
i will say bon bo james bond goldeneye
64.
oh yeah i don't know man i don't know
just the difference that we got now you
know it's so funny
well the thing that kills me with that i
went back and played a little while ago
is the one stick thing how did we ever
do
one stick i know right controller
it's such a weird controller do you do
you have i was always
pistols caves did you do you have a
config that you like or that you
remember a golden knight
uh donkey kong asked me what kind of no
no
no in goldeneye in goldeneye i always
loved like
like playing the caves level but with
only pistols because then you had to
really know
how to go you know to sneak up on
somebody in goldeneye did you have a
favorite level and a favorite weapon
no i didn't i can't i don't remember any
of that you're just good with that
no i i i played it maybe once in a blue
moon and it's
it's so hard to play now so i don't
really yeah i don't i don't know
anything about that game i just know i
still have the disc
just slappers only you just run around
yeah yeah
slapper's only i love it you said you
were dipping back into
uh mario kart on n64 right oh yeah
that's my favorite game oh man who's
your who's your choice
i always go um bowser okay
all right i've always spent
well my favorite game is super smash
bros but i'm not good at it so i can't
enjoy it as much
i've never been the best at that game so
i gotta go mario kart i like i like that
game too much
yeah smash man i i just get my ass
beat smash it's me too everyone's doing
those
abilities and i i'm throwing like a
little ball at him the whole time you
know
that's true it doesn't matter who i play
sonia are you a smash
do you play smash so this i mean this is
why i'm even more excited about this
conversation because the only smash that
i really played was on n64 i haven't
played like any of the new smash or
anything
but um yeah i mean i would rock captain
falcon
and samus that was kind of my go-to but
yeah yeah yeah
what about you i was uh that was the
falcon
falcon captain falcon that was the one
where i could use his ability
um and then jigglypuff because i was
always getting knocked off the edge and
i could just fly back
so jigglypuff was always good to recover
so good